this right here what i'm holding is what
you call a portable blood pressure
monitor right so which means you're at
the office you want to get your blood
pressure you're in the road you're
traveling
you just take it out boom measure
yourself oh it's high it's medium it's
low
and the reason why i'm showing you this
is because there's a lot of things you
can do as an entrepreneur
c-suite executive sales salesperson or
ceo that can increase your blood
pressure
and today we're going to cover what
those things are
that could cause your blood pressure and
your business to go up
so point number one which is a story of
a ceo i spoke to last week that prompted
me wanting to make this video so this
year
is uh running a business that soon five
million dollars a year who he bought the
business from his dad when he was only
doing a million dollars here so he's got
a business on paper this guy's killing
it he took his dad's business
he 5xed it however the dad when he had
it at one million
he was netting six percent even a small
margins which is only sixty thousand
dollars
but the son takes it over takes it to
five million and his margins go to one
percent
which is fifty thousand dollars so a one
million dollar business was netting more
than a five million dollar business
exactly so i said how did this happen he
said i don't know
i said how stressed out are you he said
pat very much so
i said how's your blood pressure pretty
high i said do you know how you got here
no clue i said is this part of your
strategy meaning maybe you got an
investor angel you got a lot of savings
on the max so you're putting everything
back into the business
to grow to 20 30 40 50 million because
you're backed up you're not it says
absolutely not i don't have a lot of
savings i said okay
then we got a problem and the point
number one is two problems one
no savings okay two your
your margins are so low that if you
continue this way
and you don't study the margins
eventually you're gonna have to shut
down your business so
what is the solution to point number one
here's the solution point number one
always have respect for having cash yes
that i'm at the ocean with my kids
and my daughter senna we're going in the
ocean and i always whisper to my sons
and i say to them every time i'm by the
ocean i tell them this
i said what's the rule with the ocean
they said daddy
always respect the ocean because ocean
is the most powerful thing in the world
you cannot disrespect the ocean
i said but if you respect the ocean you
can have a relationship for a long time
yes
yes daddy perfect we like the ocean
let's just make sure we're respected
yes we will great right always respect
cash
in business if you have cash and you're
respecting a game of business that
growing and you have cash you can have a
relationship for a long time
but the moment you start disrespecting
having cash in business
you don't pay attention to your margins
all of a sudden
you'll find yourself having to shut down
your business point number two look
everything in life has a formula what
does it mean that everything has a
formula everything has a formula
you know diet plus exercise plus proper
sleep and rest equals growth
and minimizing body fat percentage
hypothetically i'm just throwing that
out there
but everything has a formula in your
business i was having a conversation
with another ceo on tone
when i it was himself his wife and his
partners and they're sitting there
saying you know
business has grown we're growing at 40
we're growing at this as a
what do i do to grow it even faster i
said tell me your formulas this is what
do you mean i said what formulas do you
have
he says i don't understand okay for
example
this number of calls in this time period
with this many visits equals this many
cells he says i don't have any formulas
like that i say if you don't have
formulas like that
how do you drive your business so i said
your homework
is to sit down and come up with 10
formulas in your business
and those formulas could be how to run a
meeting five keys to running a good
meeting
boom boom boom boom boom great how to
drive my sales team i need this versus
this versus this what do i do as a ceo
bottom best dev operations gross linear
top exponential leadership development
and innovative campaign great
these are formulas the more formulas you
have the more confident you are to drive
your business
what makes blood pressure go up is if
you as a leader
don't have formulas to drive your
business point number three that could
increase your
blood pressure is not studying and
auditing your business on a regular
basis and what do i mean by auditing
auditing doesn't just mean numbers
auditing does mean numbers but that's
one part of it so you look at your
business okay
let me see what's going on with the
numbers for example i have a uh you know
a platform here that i can look at i
wake up every single morning
any second of the day any time of the
day any whatever i do
i log on to the website that we have and
i can see
how all the data how we compare
last year february january same day
as of the sixth as of the 13th as of the
28th
in 10 different markers because that's
exactly the number i need to know and i
look at and say why is this number down
why is that number down why is this done
by the way before we had this
you have to know that we did this
manually and we did this for
years but i didn't do it in my first two
three years of the business it was more
kind of like well let's just go grow the
business all this other stuff
eventually if you don't audit your
business what ends up happening
is you're you're identifying new leaks
being created in your ship
and the more leaks the ship has
eventually sync right so
when you audit you're like okay what do
we have in the people in this area to
help out we don't have a middle
management we need a middle manager what
do we have going on this area to okay we
don't uh what's our accounting form oh
they're kind of slow getting back to us
on the audit so we gotta figure
something out over here
everything is constantly you're checking
you're auditing whether
some things need to be added quarterly
some things need to be added monthly
some things need to be audited weekly
but there are things that need to be
audited
daily you need to take a piece of paper
and write down what do i audit yearly
quarterly monthly weekly and daily and
then
put a plan together to audit those areas
in your business
so it doesn't increase your blood
pressure point number four brother what
is the whole point about blood pressure
i'm not a doctor i'm not trying to tell
you what blood pressure means it's
really stresses what i'm talking about
right when he got the headache
throb and migraine or headache you get
and you're wondering why you got it
point number four
no new leaders being developed if
i see an organization and i go visit the
office it's the same faces
same leaders this month last month six
months ago a year ago two years ago
three years ago
let me put it to you this way if i'm
running that business i am under a lot
of stress
because no new leaders are being built
and if you don't constantly
replenish an organization with new
leaders and you're developing them that
are coming up rising stars
you know and you have a deep bench of
people that you can pick this person put
it here
pick that person put it here the future
of the company is a little bit
concerning because
you need new leaders every time there's
new leaders there's a little bit of
threat
of other people okay i also want to rise
up and there's also a little bit of
opportunity hey
it shows that this company is developing
people that are moving up and it shows
there's a lot of good things that happen
the more new leaders are in place so
what do you do about this
go pull up your org chart and sit down
and say mary how long has mary been here
when she first came here what was she
she was probably a three now she's a six
okay good
okay let's look at jack when jack first
came he was this now he's this okay we
so how about new people that we have
well it's been pretty much the same
faces we got to go recruit because
just like in the movie glengarry glenn
ross they say
always be closing you know what mine is
always
be recruiting for new talent to help
grow your company
to the next level so make a list of what
you have
what leaders have you built and who you
need to go recruit
next ready we're back at it again blood
pressure stress point number five
it's compliance and legal and here's
what i mean by compliance and legal
we're living in a very different time
right now which means
it's not just compliance of your
industry to know what's going on with
the new rules new guidelines new
regulation that's coming out
it's also protecting the company in case
somebody does something wrong in case
something happens with a client in case
something happens to
one of your employees you have to have
compliance in place because
for whatever reason compliance tends to
create a ton of headache
if you don't have the right leadership
team in those departments so
many times you'll talk to a executive
instruction what are you doing
all i've been doing is putting out fires
i'll sit there and i'll say if if all
i've been doing is putting out fires
all day long that means i don't have
somebody that's in the right leadership
position
why am i putting out fires all day long
i need to grow the company i get it the
fact that sometimes a leader has to get
in there and
fix the issues and process some issues
but if it's ongoing
that means some of your departments lack
good leaders and you need to find some
good leaders and departments to be
willing to
drive those departments so compliance
regulation if you do it right
and you bring the right leaders and the
right counsel they will give you a lot
of confidence
but if you don't have the right
compliance the right counsel they will
continuously call you with fires that
you have to put out
and it'll create more of this and less
of you growing the business
point number six is slightly different
because you know a lot of times i'll sit
down i'm talking to sales person let's
say let's talk to the sales leaders or
sales person or or somebody that's a
national sales director running a sales
organization
and you'll see the sales leader working
with the sales person they like a lot
but it's the wrong person they're
working with
that's not the right person to be
working with they're not going to give
you the kind of rate of return
you spend time with this person as you
think you'll have three different people
bobby johnny mary okay
and think of your time this way if for
every
10 hours you put into bobby you're gonna
get ten thousand dollars back
just throwing a number out there for
every ten hours you put into
johnny you're gonna get fifty thousand
dollars back but for every ten thousand
ten hours you put into mary you're gonna
get a hundred thousand dollars back
right
you don't know this because there's not
like a monitor let me see here okay
you're this much
we don't have that technology right but
your intuition will sit there and say
well you know what i just like this guy
more because he also likes brady like i
do
wrong reason to lock on to that person
you know but you know i like
johnny moore because johnny's into poker
like i am
wrong mary is the person that's going to
increase the value of company
so the blood pressure is when you put so
much time over here and you're wondering
how come this guy doesn't get it
it's not his fault it's your fault
because when you put time here
it's easy it's peaceful she wants to win
she wants to get to work she wants to be
coached
not putting your time into the right
people by the way the same goes with
clients
i was a stock broker i had a client if
every time the market went up this guy
called me 20 times
but every time the market and the stocks
went up he called me a hundred times
eventually i'm sitting there saying my
entire day two hours of it is with this
guy
what happened what happened what
happened what happened why did it happen
why did it happen
and i'm like oh my gosh this is too much
i'm like how much money have i made off
this guy and then i get the numbers i'm
like
it's just not worth it it's just not
worth it and i said johnny i just don't
think i'm the right guy for you what are
you talking about
what do you know you can say i'm i can i
refer you to somebody else because i'm
not the guy
and i referred it to another guy in the
office i wanted it he took it and guess
what
he was miserable i said i'm telling you
he's having no i'll take it don't worry
about i can change i know how to deal
with these kinds of clients i said okay
here's yours you got to learn on who you
work with because if you don't work with
the right clients and the right agents
and the right employees and the right
people
they're going to suck all the best
energy out of you and
increase your stress level so make sure
you lock on to the right
employees the right sales people the
right investors
the right board that you have a choice
with and the right client
or else you can waste a lot of time
being stressed out point number seven is
another one here that's uh you know you
say
so say you're running a company and i'm
talking to the ceo
like how many direct reports do you have
oh i have so we draw the orchestra i
only have five
oh okay really let's take a look at so
we start drawing this stuff on the board
i'm like who's he report to really me
how about this person
it's technically me how about this
person we came up with like
26 people that reported to this guy
direct employees
26 people that reported to this guy said
i said so let me ask you a question
how are you developing leaders here i
said how do you have any life
what are you doing he said oh it's just
it's so non-stop
i said well buddy you got to figure
something out here because way too many
people
report you directly and by the way it
was not a deep bench at all
there was no depth in the organization
there was no middle management in the
organization
he was a control guy i said let me
explain to how control works
the word control and trust go together
okay
the less you control the more you trust
the person
the more you control the less you trust
the person i had a conversation with my
son yesterday tico and i told him i said
listen you ever wonder when you read
your book and you go out and want to
play video game do i control you not at
all
you ever wonder when you're going out
there and you're playing with the sand
and you're messing around doing whatever
you're doing and you like to get really
dirty do i control you no you're okay
with me
but do you ever notice when i ask you
something and i say
today based on what you did you only can
do this much yes
do you realize if you go and still not
follow and keep your word what happens
slowly is i want to control you more
because i trust you less
but you know what i want to do buddy is
what i want to trust you more so i give
you more freedom don't you want that i
want that
so why don't we work on trust together
right when you have 26 direct reports
you don't trust your people okay so you
need to trust that some of these middle
management and some of your direct
reports can become leaders
so three goes here two goes here four
goes here and then you got
five to seven direct reports that you
can work with directly
if you don't pay attention to the amount
of direct reports that come to you
that have people layers of other people
that are developing them
you can all of a sudden catch yourself
having an entire week being gone
and saturday you're having dinner
telling yourself what did i really get
accomplished today
not much do we really grow the company
no why not
because everybody reports directly to
you
it's not a way to build a business make
adjustments asap
before you constantly stress down number
eight is the scary one for a lot of
people is you got a
issue on your desk that you know you
have to call one person and you know
it's going to be conflict and you know
it could be heated and you know it's
going to be something that the person's
not going to like you're going to have
to bring somebody in your office
have a conversation with them but you
keep delaying it one hour two hours
three hours six hours one day two days
three days four days five days
the longer you delay a conflict that
problem gets bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger why because on the other side you
don't know what the other person is
thinking
the other person's imagination is oh my
gosh maybe they did this
oh i think it's this no i think it's
this i i think it's this
it wasn't that it was just this but he
didn't make the phone call
and it would have been resolved like
this you know how many times there's
been a conflict
that before making the phone call and
having the meeting you thought it was
going to be the end of the world the
building was going to come down next
thing you know you know it's just
terrible things were going to happen and
dinosaurs were going to show up but you
know what the reality is
you sit down you're like this was
nothing
why didn't i have this meeting an hour
earlier well why not address this
yesterday why don't i do this two days
ago
nine out of ten meetings that you're
going that have to do with conflict
the sooner you meet with them you come
out saying honestly i thought it was
going to be worse
and it was nothing so stop avoiding
the conflict as a ceo as an executive as
an entrepreneur the longer you do
the problem gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and it just increases stress not
just for you but for a lot of people
point number nine i don't think enough
people put a lot of attention into this
you know the book uh the motive by
patrick lanciones says
you know a lot of times executive thing
because you you had a meeting you said
one thing one time that everybody's
gonna execute he says
the employee the average employee needs
to hear
your messaging seven times before they
realize you're serious let me say this
one more time
the average employee has to hear your
set of standards
seven times from you before they know
it's serious
seven times not just one motivational
speech oh this is how we're gonna run it
here
bam that's not how it works so i had a
call this last week and it was a
conflict we had to address
and i was on a call for a couple hours
and then i made a suggestion for another
call and we had to call
and the call that i had with this
individual they were very upset not
happy
furious and i there was there was there
was almost like a
challenge going on between two
personalities and asked this guy
question who was not happy i said let me
ask you
has this person here that you're so
upset about has he ever flirted with
your wife
he says no i said has he ever
disrespected your kids
no has he ever stolen money from you no
pat no um have they ever questioned
your faith no have they i just kept
going through have they have they have
their
no i said so what is it did he
do something or not do something that
offended you yes and by the way
valid point on why he was offended i'm
i'm telling you it was a valid point
on why he was offended but you know what
it was
what what saved it is that this man here
builds his business based on values and
principles and eventually he said
yeah i understand i said so offending
what is offending
i've both offended a lot of people and
i've made mistakes
god knows how many times but i've also
been offended
and i've been here and i've had to learn
how to bring
myself here the more i respond to being
offended here
the more this keeps going this keeps
going this keeps going the more i get
offended and i respond here
this goes and then disappears i don't
know if that makes sense or not so
your entire game of your business
long term the more you have it set on
the right
values and principles we start meetings
on time we finish them on time now you
come prepared whatever those set of
principles are
how you treat people how you respect
people how you respect spouses how you
respect kids
all of that stuff the more and more you
talk about it and the more and more you
execute it
eventually guess what goes up trust goes
higher and higher
and higher and higher and higher and the
higher trust goes up
the more people stick around the more
people come back the more people want to
work for you the more people want to be
your clients the more people want to be
around you
if you build your business on the right
set of values and principles by the way
this isn't an
instant stress this is a gradual stress
if you if you don't build your business
on advisors buys and principles
so it goes like this slowly slowly
slowed and then eventually when it gets
up guess what
it stays like this for a long time it's
painful
if you don't build your business on
values and principles because then
eventually
you can bring it back down to calm the
entire situation you got
but that storm lasts a long time address
it early so you don't have a lengthy
storm
point number 10 is annoying it's
stressful it's upsetting
and you can get very irritated with this
and this is lose a market share okay and
market share is lost
a lot of times by a leader
an executive who no longer competes like
they once used to and what i'm what i
mean by no longer confused like the ones
used to
so you used to read everything that was
going on the marketplace you used to
read all the right books you used to
always have a book or an audio
book playing you used to always work on
you used to inspire your guys you used
to drive your guys you used to get up
there and say
we're gonna be you used to cast a vision
you used to say here's what we're gonna
do
and it attracted and it lifted your
people up but you no longer do it
you now think that everybody just
because you said it a year ago five
years ago 10 years ago
they're just supposed to remember and
executed that's not how this thing
worked
losing market share is very annoying
but it happens often when the leader
is content is happy he's got an okay
life
is doing there three four times a week
of golfing it's kicking back
they think they've already made it it's
like the ceo
of gm from 1920s that said if you have
an
enterprise there is no resting in an
enterprise where there is constant
competition
there is no resting doesn't mean you
don't sleep here six to eight hours a
week a night
doesn't mean you don't go out and get
your but it does mean you have to
constantly be competing or else
you will lose market share to somebody
else
who is out working you out improving out
strategizing
and outlasting and by the way there's
competition that come and go
some of them are seasonal and then
there's real competition
you have to respect your real
competition or else they will take a
market share away from you
so a lot of technical things covering
this video i haven't done one of these
for a long time and
if you like this video there's another
one i want you to watch it's also like
this
that is about how to inspect your
business i'm all about inspecting my
business regularly if you haven't
watched this video click over here
i got numbers of areas for you to
inspect and how to go about
inspecting it again if you haven't seen
it click here to watch it take care
everybody